what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today to watch
the final trailer for Avatar the way of
water John how goes it I feel
strong
how do you feel is that a reference
isn't that what she says about the new
home tree
home tree yeah you know the big old tree
that they plug their tail feathers into
when does anger Cora do any of that okay
guys all right let's watch this leave a
like before you do
[Music]
holy crap
this is going to be us throughout the
whole movie damn
you come to us
nope I just want to keep my family safe
nice
there you go as our brothers and sisters
wow
sport
if you want to live here
this looks great
the water
oh my God just breathe
breathe
hey that's handshock yeah
stunning
cast that's all they see
I see
I see you I see you
why are you like you I'm supposed to
fight this music is so swelling
wow
that was a is that a Stephen langatar
I think so
my goodness wowie my goodness
oh yes
Avatar the way of water tickets on sale
boy oh boy that was mesmerizing
absolutely mesmerizing sort of attending
a wedding
two days before this comes out
I might be in it
I might be saying and I do that day oh
God I don't know so uh I don't know if
it's as important as Avatar I might have
to
cancel my own wedding Greg's really late
I gotta get my review up woman yeah
I think this is cutting down a too long
review oh wow that looks just absolutely
mesmerizing I can't wait to see the
different sides of the culture than the
new sea creatures to explore on top of
all of that too the action just has this
like strangely kinetic visceral energy
with like this strange kind of shutter
speed to it that feels like an anime
again yeah you just keep wanting to say
that yeah it just looks so swelling and
like a just a fantastic visual Feast of
an experience needless to say three
hours 14 minutes I think is what the run
time is for this yeah and that's also
how long every cast member can hold
their breath underwater I know it's
impressive what'd you think John I was
dazzled by this and I love the fact that
with both of these trailers they are
really just leaning into tone food you
know the general Aura I mean like you
get a lot of action in this trailer this
is a great international trailer because
it's like yeah they're not giving us the
exact plot but you could you you know
what the main conflict is gonna be
you're gonna have machines versus the
natural world of the navi and uh yeah it
just looks so swelling and gripping and
everything underwater it is magical to
watch this because you know just how
much Innovation and how many effects
brought all these shots to life but and
yet they feel like you just plopped a
camera there which I love that Duality
because it could easily be distracting
and yet somehow it's like I I could tell
but also I'm just so enamored with yeah
how lovely and beautiful this all looks
yeah I thought this one really leaned
heavily into the action as well but at
the very beginning this is the most
dialogue I feel like we've gotten from
the navi themselves as well and I don't
know the name of this other culture that
we're going to be dealing with I I want
to go on a little bit more blind to this
than than usual you know like I'm not
really actively researching to see what
the details of the plot are I do think
there's going to be an interesting kind
of clash and exploration to to be had
there as well because they're very
different kinds of people as well you
know which I think helps separate it's a
movie that the first one especially
dealt with like and that's going to
carry over the segregation themes those
racism themes that they're going to be
dealing with it's good to be getting
like you know show that not all of them
are the same on this planet you know
yeah yeah maybe there will be conflicts
from within the different tribes and
whatnot I mean it seemed like they were
fixing for a conflict with Cliff Curtis
there uh when he's like what are you
coming here looking for our help you
know at the same time it also feels like
it's about Community sure continuously
like you get a lot of these really like
family themes it's a unique thing about
Avatar is that as epic of a scale as
this this film is it also is so much
about family it's one the whole family
gets yeah I feel like this will be the
biggest movie of the year I mean I think
we're all opting for like one of the
Marvel movies but I feel like this one
I'll do them yeah because you could just
feel you really can feel feel the event
that this is and you could feel how 10
years it took to make it yeah in a way
that's totally different than something
like a Boyhood or whatever you're like
wow like having we we were all a lot of
us were there for the original Avatar
and for the innovations that that made
and then to see like the Leaps and
Bounds after all the many years of memes
and people debating as to whether or not
it deserves to be the highest grossing
film ever like you you really feel the
double down in terms of just like
craftsmanship yeah that went into this
and I feel like people that's movie
Magic and people respond to that I mean
and it looks like they're just embracing
the war aspect of it whereas the first
one was like territorial Invasion it was
so much about we gotta prevent a war
from breaking out we got to prevent a
battle from breaking out and of course
that's not what happened you know it got
really nasty and ugly in the last hour
of that film but so much about it was
preventing that and now it seems like
the goddamn us of a yeah well back we're
coming back looking for unobtaining yeah
they're stepping in there and they're
like no screw it we're just going out
like we're hauling ass in there we're
gonna create all kinds of chaos we don't
care we got it the only way to do it is
by resorting to violence you know so it
seems like the necessity of them banding
together but of course you know also
exploring
um Jake and uh natiri's what's her name
that Terry yeah all right
Nokia well I was about to say the word
the colonizers but you're seeing Jake
and Terry's family too and exploring uh
their lives as children yeah yeah yeah
yeah and what it's saying having some of
those those romances seeing the other
hot Navi girl from the water emerging
yeah yeah yeah it's beautiful it's gonna
be just all that shot of Phoebe Cates
from uh whatever that high school movie
is but just with Navi and their tiny
tiny little garments yeah they also got
some like great POV shots like it looks
like James Cameron's really toying with
perspective a lot in this trailer too
yeah I mean this in the least insulting
way possible it looks like the coolest
video game ever yeah no it looks like a
great video game yeah totally um Jack in
the VR and yeah looks amazing guys what
do you think about this trailer leave
your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
hopefully we get a press screening that
way I don't have to piss your way
[Laughter]
priorities babe and Hey listen for the
patron of the day shout out
Brandon Benzie Brandon you've been part
of our patreon page for four months now
and I hope to see you for another 12
more months that's right then we can
renegotiate 16 months but in the
meantime you are flowing through here so
well like water get what I just did
there hey and I I love that you love us
to this degree and the best way to show
love is by money and so by you giving
money to US monthly on a consistent
basis I feel loved that is the key to
anyone's heart unconditionally Scholars
so your supporter patreon has been uh
very very very much appreciative and in
all sincerity I hope you have a
wonderful Thanksgiving in Tucson Arizona
yeah I hope you have an amazing time out
there hope it doesn't get too hot and uh
sweaty but then you know it also leads
to a lot of very beautiful people no
matter what orientation you are gay
straight everyone's gonna be shirtless
in some capacity still have a good time
regardless get sweaty this Thanksgiving
buddy way of sweat
[Music]